hi everyone hi i'm joanna what's the
terence
and today we are back in the kitchen to
cook together again
so today we'll be making three healthy
rice bowl recipes
yup his favorite and my favorite will be
soy honey glazed salmon rice bowl and
of course for vegans we also have a
recipe for you which will be
tempeh kimchi rice bowl super delicious
ok
this here is very high in protein and
it's a really great source of protein
for vegans
so that's the three recipes we'll be
making
yep as for my recipe you'll need one
salmon fillet so this salmon right here
is about
200 grams before cooked all right and
for the marinade sauce you'll need soya
sauce
rice vinegar as well as honey and of
course a little bit of garlic as well
just to add that extra
flavor for my vegetables i like to keep
it really simple
cherry tomatoes cucumber and my favorite
edamame again edamame is very high in
protein
and the final vegan recipe we will need
about 150 grams of tempeh kimchi
about quarter cup of kimchi okay for
those of you who are wondering oh
who are saying that i don't like this i
don't like that why not give it a try
kimchi is actually very high in
probiotics
so kimchi is actually very good for your
digestion
you don't have to eat too much of it
just a little bit
okay so shall we start cooking okay
let's start by slicing all the
vegetables as well as the meat
okay now just take a new roast
i'm going to be slicing my temper into
thin slices
so neuron set up
this is a great way to add flavors to
your food without the additional
calories
we'll be using lots of spices later on
as well
you can take garlic
foreign
i'm going to be making the marination
which i'll be using for the salmon
as well as the tempeh okay so what
you'll need is about two tablespoons of
soya sauce
one tablespoon of rice vinegar so mix it
all together
and also one tablespoon of honey alright
so mix it all together into a bowl
and of course garlic so i'm going to add
a little bit of garlic
into it yep
and just mix it
while he's doing that i'm going to brush
the marinade onto the salmon as well as
tempeh
and place it onto this baking tray
so with ingredients like this you don't
need to add any more salt because
soy is actually salty it's very high in
sodium
this is ready before you put it into the
oven
let it sit for at least 15 minutes long
okay let it sit
let all the marinade soak in to the
salmon as well as tempeh and then we'll
bake it okay
well
[Applause]
i'll be slicing the cucumber as well as
cherry tomatoes
and i'll be using these vegetables and
top it up onto my rice bowl
later on so for those of you who find it
very troublesome you want to do less
cooking
you can choose this type of vegetables
because you can eat them raw
and that's how i like it okay keep it
simple keep it quick
these chilies are from his father's
garden hence they're all in different
shapes and sizes
because they're organic and they're
actually really
spicy you can't just eat them directly
it's gonna
really burn your mouth but i know he
loves spice so
okay shang thai santa
he cooks every day okay so yeah he's
been cooking for what 15 years now on
your own
yeah it's actually really fun when we
get to cook together
so this edamame has been boiled i'm just
removing
the skin so that i can
simply top this onto the rice bowl later
on
i love edamame okay
we are almost done and after this we can
start cooking holloma howla
awesome this is ready we're going to
bake it in the oven for about
15 to 20 minutes or until your salmon is
fully cooked through
all right this goes in
woo-hoo hot
okay all right okay
set out my turn yep okay actually it's
getting euros
sesame oil we like to use sesame oil
because it
it's actually more suitable for asian
cooking
so again when it comes to oil don't put
too much
soap
on
again if you don't want to use beef you
can also use any other meat of your
choice for example chicken
or even yeah fish as well right cooked
until it's slightly golden brown and
fragrant we can already start smelling
it it smells
so good in this kitchen right now just
onions okay
time for that oh you have to go in
this is actually enough for two portions
okay
i'm not a big fan of beef to be honest i
have always been a fish person
so yeah i eat fish on a daily basis yeah
that's my preference actually
over beef or even chicken wanna
yo
here
he eats everything okay if you can't
finish anything just pass it to him
he'll eat it as long as it's healthy if
it's rubbish or if it's junk food
then he won't eat it
okay so what's next chili um
sauce oh teriyaki sauce
don't use too much of this
pizza
so that is going to add that a little
bit of sweetness
and also a little bit of um saltiness to
the dish
so
you can actually smell and feel the
spice
from the beef this chili is really spicy
it's going to sneeze that's how spicy it
is
it's going to sneeze okay
oh my god
[Music]
lots and lots of parsley
as you can see all the flavors and
seasoning most of them are from natural
foods such as parsley chili
and onion the only additional was the
teriyaki sauce and we only used
a little bit so this is how you want to
be
flavoring your food with natural
ingredients it smells
really good you can really
smell that freshness from the parsley
and also the spiciness from the chili
okay
[Music]
[Music]
my salmon and tempeh is done so i'm
going to remove it and
let it cool down
wow smells good
it may look slightly burned that's
because of the soy sauce so don't worry
okay
this is not burnt it's just brown
because of the soy sauce
and also honey so the only thing that's
left to cook
will be the spinach as well as eggs we
love
eggs on our rice bowl
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so this is going to cook really fast
okay we don't want to overcook it
we want it to still be crunchy a little
bit great so it should cook really fast
see it's already um starting to wilt and
it's almost done
how long there you go that's it
we're going to make sunny side up
or as how we call it in malaysia
mata kerbal let's do it okay a little
bit of black pepper
all the ingredients are cooked and ready
so now we're going to assemble
our rice bowl this is the fun part
so let's start with the base okay rice
you can choose any rice of your choice
typically people like to use um japanese
rice but we prefer basmati rice
because it's very soft and flaky
so typically when you go out and eat
rice bowl
one bowl is not enough for him so he
likes to use a big bowl here so that he
can top it up with more protein as well
okay enough enough all right
all right so for me it's going to be
about one small bowl of rice
okay so remember portion control okay
not
too much that's enough now the third
bowl
let's see who does it better okay and
because this is your own rice bowl
make sure to be generous with your
protein and also vegetables
three
yep that's right presentation matters
yes
[Music]
i like my rice bowl to be colorful hence
you can see
i'm using cherry tomatoes cucumber and
also edamame
so arrange them nicely and be generous
with your vegetables
and colorful okay okay look at
mine alright
so while he's still slowly arranging his
beef i'm gonna start assembling the
tempeh kimchi bowl
this is a great option for vegans
and finally your favorite kimchi
so if this is like very foreign to you
start with
just a tablespoon that's fine okay if
you love kimchi
then be more generous and go for more
but don't overdo it
[Music]
okay yep
one for me okay you're not taking both
please okay sometimes you will just
eat all the eggs and not leave any for
me
okay
and finally let's top it up with a
little bit of chili flakes and also
sesame seeds
all right just a little bit see
that's gonna add more colors to your
dish and also flavor
wait what a meal yeah wait hang on
yours has so much chili already so you
don't need it
sesame seed and chili flakes if you want
to you can also add black pepper
or even other spices
all right
voila done look at them
so colorful i am so ready to eat they
look so
appetizing this is done look at them
they look
so good and i know it's going to taste
good
today just a woman thinking so tombeda
healthy rice bowl yup very easy and very
quick as well and the great thing is
that if you want to take them out you
can do that as well
all you have to do is separate the
ingredients so we have
chili onion beef rice bowl soy honey
glazed
salmon rice bowl and of course a vegan
version
tempeh kimchi rice bowl
don't be afraid to eat your rice okay
remember it's all about portion control
correct
water juice
you have to understand portion control
and if you're looking to lose weight
then keep it to one to two small bowls
of rice a day
remember that it all comes down to
living a balanced lifestyle so move
daily
exercise daily and eat a well-balanced
diet as well
all right are we ready
this is always my favorite part of
basically filming a cooking video which
is to actually
eat the food
so good i can taste the sweetness
from the honey and also the saltiness
slight saltiness from the soy
what
don't forget to give these recipes a try
let us know in the comments below
which is your favorite and if you do
have any rice ball recipes let us know
in the comments below
and also like this video share this
video on
and if you like to watch more cooking
videos with the both of us
then let us know in the comments below
rice ball yup and we'll see you next
time
bye
[Music]
you